[Music]
when you're a smaller competitor taking
on the big guys you have to come up with
fun sometimes outrageous ways of getting
your brand know and getting on the front
pages because you just don't have the
advertising spend of the big guys try to
do things that make people smile even if
you make a fool of yourself
[Music]
taking notes has been the most important
thing that i've done in building
businesses i went to space and it was an
incredible day in my life
but i had a list of 35 things that i
felt need to be improved upon when i was
floating i felt there should be a handle
on the seats that go on the walls that
you could grab hold of
if i hadn't written
some of these things down i would have
forgotten about them i've already
forgotten about them until i just read
them now
buy yourself a notebook
[Music]
people who use the i word too much put
people off
and rightfully so if you're in a team of
people it's very important that you talk
about
us or we or try
to avoid the i word
unless less is absolutely necessary and
your business is likely to excel as a
result
[Music]
you